Тут поєднують ручну працю та новітні технології.
У цій теплиці вирощують 300 мільйонів балконних і садових рослин, а також овочі для всієї Європи.
Це Emsflower - компанія, яка володіє найбільшою теплицею в Європі.
Вона більша, ніж 80 футбольних полів.
Ось п'ять причин успіху цієї компанії.
Перша причина: екологічність.
Сесілія Швеннен - наш гід.
Ми їздимо на велосипеді навколо теплиць завдовжки півтора кілометра.
Це здоровий і швидкий спосіб пересування для більшості з 400 працівників компанії.
Цього тижня тут збирають врожай - 120 тонн помідорів.
Нові квіти потрібно обпилкувати.
Одну з найважливіших функцій тут виконують комахи.
У нас тут кілька сотень тисяч джмелів. Це дуже важливі працівники.
Сонечка теж допомагають, поїдаючи шкідливу попелицю.
Завдяки корисним комахам і личинкам тут менше користуються інсектицидами.
Друга причина: автоматизація.
Роботи, як оцей, можуть висаджувати 15 000 саджанців за годину.
Це єдиний спосіб засадити айстрами цілі зали.
Один із винаходів, який тут використали вперше, - ось такі упаковки.
Ці набори саджанців лаванди постачають у супермаркети-дискаунтери.
Товар забирають самокеровані машини.
Третя причина успіху: локація.
Теплиці розташовані в центрі Європи, на півночі Німеччини, неподалік від кордону з Нідерландами.
Керівник компанії Том Квіперс вирішив будувати нові теплиці навколо штаб-квартири компанії.
Він називає це правильним рішенням.
Ми розташовані поруч із автобаном і маємо чудове сполучення з півночі на південь та зі сходу на захід.
Ми можемо швидко дістатися до будь-якої точки Європи. Це величезна перевага для нас.
Цю розсаду привезли з філіалу компанії в Ефіопії, розташованому неподалік від столиці - Аддис-Абеби.
У тамтешній теплиці Emsflower працюють близько 600 людей.
Четверта причина успіху: родинний бізнес.
Emsflower заснував у 1954 році Ян Квіперс. Сьогодні компанією керують його онуки.
Emsflower - лідер галузі з 1990-х років.
Гендиректор Том Квіперс добре знається на інноваціях і вірить у модель сімейного бізнесу.
Якщо ви хочете зробити щось нове, це не принесе прибуток наступного року.
Компанії, чиї акції торгуються на фондовому ринку, хочуть бачити прибутки негайно.
А сімейний бізнес хоче бути певним, що він існуватиме через 10 чи 15 років.
П'ята причина: ощадливість.
Зазвичай теплиці споживають багато води й тепла.
Тут на дахах встановлені сонячні панелі, а надлишок виробленої електроенергії щодня повертається в мережу.
Теплицю опалюють не газом, а відходами від дерев.
З екологічної точки зору це краще і значно дешевше.
Опалення також забезпечує електростанція, яка працює на деревині. Надлишок струму потрапляє в мережу.
Ми хочемо кліматично нейтральне опалення.
Ми виробляємо предмети розкоші.
Покупці повинні купувати їх із чистим сумлінням, тому ми повинні відійти від викопного палива.
Дощова вода з дахів 90-гектарного об'єкту потрапляє в резервуари, а звідти - в систему зрошування.
Звісно, це не безкоштовно, але це також корисніше для квітів.
Дощова вода не містить багато вапна, і це ще одна велика перевага: рослини люблять дощову воду.
У ці басейни додають добрива для кожного виду рослин.
Підлога в теплиці герметична, тож воду, яка капає згори, збирають унизу і знову використовують.
Головна причина успіху цієї компанії - економне використання грошей і ресурсів.